would you call the border secure  it's good it's going to be good it's  going to be good i think that there is  no question that we have to do what the  president and i asked congress to do the  first request we made  pass a  bill to create a pathway to citizenship  the border is secure we're gonna have  two million people cross this border for  the first time ever you're confident  this border's secure  we have  a secure border you keep using the horde  i don't think it means what you think it  means that is a priority for any nation  including ours in our administration she  is so extraordinarily vapid i am  actually man between her and buying it's  like biden doesn't know what he's saying  come on and we'll just read anything end  of quote repeat the line with her it's  as if they put her out there having no  knowledge of anything and she strings  together words in the most circular way  to say absolutely  nothing